foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm just gonna wait here for a while is
that cool hello and welcome to another
episode of black man beyond my name is
Mark Bernard it will be your solo host
on tonight's Voyage into the unknown in
tonight's wonderful gallivant into the
Galaxy of geekness
I don't know what I'm doing boys and
girls it's been a while
um but hey how are you hey oh hey
um it has been as I said a couple weeks
since uh
um since Ed Bruce baker has it been a
couple of weeks it feels like a couple
of weeks maybe I don't know what time is
dilating in the weirdest possible ways
uh because I've been doing [ __ ] you guys
I've been dealing [ __ ]
um but yes we talked to Ed Brubaker who
was on the podcast I have a lovely Deep
dive into his writing habits and his
writing style and his stuff he's works
on and how he does the things that he
does we're talking about Canberra back
at the Cantina
um for a free whirling free whirling
free wheeling um uh somewhat insane chat
which are my favorite kind of chats but
uh with guests this year about fat man
black man in space
um but today we have a lot to talk we
have some [ __ ] that I have seen
namely
um I'm caught up on Andor I've seen
Black Adam
um JC and I will talk about the rings of
power and the hot D
um season finale's
um I can talk a little bit about what it
was like to be on the purple carpet of
wakanda forever
um I'm gonna have a bunch of news to
talk about we'll hit q a at the very end
of it but before we go very much deeper
into uh today tonight's
uh full to bursting ripping at the seams
um uh heaving bosom of an episode uh we
opened some bills we've got some ads to
read well I have some answers which
means we'll be out of here pretty well
um we are going to kick off our uh our
double ad Bonanza
with a word or two from our good Folks
at nativedeo.com
when it comes to personal hygiene it was
time to read that long list of
ingredients in the back of the bottle
some ingredients I can't even pronounce
and if you're like me and care about
what goes on your body but it's time to
try native personal care products just
like I did every native product is
totally formulated and keep you feeling
it's smelling fresh all day long you
know native for their aluminum free
deodorant native keeps their ingredients
list bare naked with ingredients that
you can understand like coconut oil shea
butter and baking soda the native
deodorant checks a lot of boxes 72 hour
odor protection naturally derived
ingredients and a smooth residue-free
activation native also offers a variety
of scents with new and limited editions
since being released all the time
like warm cider and a cinnamon
cashmere and Rain yeah toasted
marshmallow what and vanilla oh Wildwood
and cardamom hey mom
um yo want to smell spicy or woodsy
clean and fresh native has a scent
option for everyone the amounts of time
to make a switch from antipers for the
opinion native and when you visit their
site you can discover all their fresh
scents maybe even try out one for one of
their body washes while you're at it so
smell fresh and smell clean and smell
fresh and clean all day long with Native
get 20 off your first order by going to
nativedeo.com Batman or use the promo
code Fatman in checkout that's
nativedeo.com Batman or use a promo code
Fatman at checkout for 20 off your first
order and we fact the good folks in the
native for making us smell so fresh come
on so clean
um all right so what should we get into
what should we do I think let me talk
very quickly about uh Black Adam
which I did see opening week
um and you know it is certainly it is
doing uh well enough at the box office
has made something under 12 million
dollars worldwide and 10 days of release
um and uh and and The Rock definitely
fills out a superhero suit uh on Dwayne
Johnson I'm not sure if I was supposed
to use this confirmation man
um but uh regardless I mean if you guys
have seen the movie you know the movie
is by now
um I'm not I'm not I don't think pulling
the rug out from anybody and I don't
know the gun punctually any any
long-held balloons about what it is
um it's a bit of a mess
um and I and and I think the the two
things that exemplified this to me the
most were
um I don't know at any point in that
movie
what Black Adam wants
um I don't know why he's doing any of
the things he's doing he comes out of
you know his
is uh his his Millennia old prison and
he just starts crunching things he we
don't know why he goes into the city we
know why he kills the people who are
shooting at him better again but why
he's in conduct what he expects to get
out of conduct why he helps out this
family why he's taking a shot into this
kid
um because they make it a mystery that
he had a son and a wife even though
anybody who's in the trailers no that's
why he turned into blackout
um
you know what what is it about this
family that that makes him do anything
why does he want to punch the Justice
Society so badly and why do the Justice
decide to want to punch himself
um that was sort of my other problem in
that I don't know who the Justice
Society is I mean I
oh we know we know but why are they this
weird International jurisdiction in
every Force
completely uh held that on dealing with
blackout when there's nothing but crime
in this place they could have cleared up
anytime they wanted to
um it uh there's there's a there's a
term I'll call it euphemism that's used
when like the sitcoms because most
September episodes are
somebody's acting stupid and everybody
needs to
um recover from it deal with it whatever
they call it it's called The Idiot ball
who's caring the idiot ball this week
and it seemed as if Carter Hall was kind
of needed involved more than more often
than not because it's with a
conversation that could stop having to
beat each other up but nobody's willing
to have the conversation instead let's
start punching
which doesn't make any sense any of the
times that they do it there's an inter
gang that disappears halfway through the
movie is a threat and then isn't at all
there's a bad guy who wants a thing to
get killed so that he can some kind of
fine power in death but then again he
probably could have been killed anytime
they wanted to be
um you know it just it's
it's fine if you like that kind of thing
um I traditionally do like that coffee
so it's not 11.
um but hey it's doing well enough at the
box office there will be more
um Black Adams to come I would not be
spoiling anything to say that Henry
Cavill does show up with Superman about
Midway through the the credits
um and I kept on hoping that would
happen as a third Act of the movie which
it personally doesn't really have one
um and so
uh you know because now you're teasing
me the thing that I'm not going to get
for years and years and years and I
don't even know what the shift of it is
going to be
um
as opposed to you know and this is not a
a marvelous DC comparison but when you
tease The Avengers you're not teasing
the conflict you're teasingly plot which
is fine what this movie does is it
teaches a conflict that we're never
going to get resolved or if we do it's
not going to be for a long long while to
come and so excuse me
um that's kind of where I was like I
mean sure okay I guess I'll do that
um but yeah you know I had a good enough
time at it there's some of those
sequences are fun
but then there's just the things that
they they just manifested this out of it
didn't want to make a movie about mainly
there's a guy who was born in
6 000 BC who wakes up and speaks perfect
in English
um is never once flummoxed At All by the
modern world
um
and just doesn't believe indoors even
though they have 100 indoors 6 000 BC
um
but hey I hope you dug it if you dug it
um
you know you're gonna get more if you
did
um and I guess dovetailing along the
blackout of it all
um one of the big news events that we
didn't get to cover
um was that James Gunn is now uh with
Peter safri going to be heading up DC
Studios
um which you know is kind of great
because I think that one of the things
that DC has needed is they've needed
somebody they needed a Creator
um to help Shepard
um their their universe and not just a
creative but a creative with a distance
because
you know Jeff Johns was also doing you
know either a job like this or this
specific job for a while
um and Jeff Johns is a very nice dude
incredibly talented writer but
I always got the feeling that he was so
close to this material that he was
deeply invested in half the time because
he wrote these characters on on the page
and I think that what what a position
office requires is knowledge but also a
a ability to distance yourself from that
knowledge and to make the changes one
needs to make in order for it to sort of
live and breathe as movies and not just
as as translations from the page and so
to have something like like James God be
that person or at least one of those
people
um is is I think it's a pretty good idea
I think it's a pretty good idea because
you want a Creator you want somebody who
makes this stuff to do this stuff
um
I do not interview him the task said
before him as we talked before about
when Dan was up for this job he got
produced political movies
um because it's a big lift it's you know
what do you do with the things you've
inherited how much do you keep how much
do you how much do you Scuttle you know
you've already got a couple of things in
motion that you probably can't do much
to to alter namely there's going to be
Batman stuff you know from the for the
Matt Reeves Camp there's going to be a
penguin TV show which we'll talk about
later there's a Batman two there's you
know all kinds of stuff there that is
kind of interwoven into that into that
version of Batman and then there's a
joker Sequel and then there's a Harley
Quinn show and then there's probably a
Black Adam too and whatever they're
doing with the nine different Supermen
that they've decided to to begin to to
make into movies
um yeah I don't know I don't know what
uh you know how you go about
refurbishing a mansion that still has
all the furniture in it that some people
still seem to a lot of people but
doesn't entirely work as one thing
you know how hard do you lean into being
Multiverse that DC has had since you
know almost its Inception
um and how much do you try to unify and
make it a singular version of what these
stories could be I don't even answer
that
um but I think that that
James Gunn can can get on the phone can
get on the zoo and get get in a room
with the people who can can help him
figure that out
so it's encouraging to me it's a good
sign
um
well what else Black Adam Jake's gun
um what kind of forever
so I have been on the internet
um as I want to do
um around about a month ago lamenting
the fact that I was going to have to do
the heavy lift they're trying to get
somebody try to con somebody into
inviting me to the one time for
everything
um the economy didn't require that much
like I didn't have to put up any
physical collateral I didn't promise the
firstborn child I didn't have to do any
of that stuff
um to score a uh to find a way to be
somebody plus one
um because I still do have some friends
in that world and they they one of them
was kind enough to reach out and invite
me along
um it was it was a it was a wonderful
night
um a very celebratory night and by
celebratory I don't often I don't always
mean like Rara let's cheer because
I'm not gonna spoil anything by saying
this I think it's evident from all of
the trailers
um this movie is awake this movie is a
let us
process the loss of both Chadwick
Boseman and t'challa
um and and the movie very much engages
with that as a real thing and so the
night was very much kind of in this
feeling of
you know not funeral because it wasn't
Grim but it was it was celebratory of a
life
whereas the First Premiere you know back
in 2018
was was a party you know it was it was a
coronation in lots of different ways you
know it's a coordination of Chadwick as
as to child's coronation of Ryan coogler
as as a filmmaker who can achieve at the
highest levels of Marvel and you know
rolling a dice and making a movie this
triumphantly black
um it was a it was a it was a
celebration of sort of black Hollywood
and black you know elitism and the Black
Elite in Hollywood and pop culture
everywhere
um so there was definitely a bouncier
feeling than that first one where this
was a little bit more song
but it was it's it is so great to see
it's all great to be back out and in the
world again it's so great to sit in that
house in the Dolby Theater
um and and laugh with people about a
movie like this cry with people about a
movie like this and there's three or
four times for sure when they do not
pull punches in uh and go in for the
emotional heft of it all
um but I think that's that's all I'll
say about that night
um and that's all I'll say about them
because we still do have at this point
10 days
um as of today November 1st for anybody
else to see it
um and I will not be the person to spoil
anything about this other than to say
um
it is as he emotionally charged and
really that I've seen in a long time and
that charge comes from both within the
drama and from everything surrounding it
um
so
so yeah so uh what kind of forever
um Black Adam
James gunning
um and I think maybe it might be fine
for a Bev man
to journey to talk about a couple of
other things
before we dig in do you are you a
Halloween person
um and not especially
so I'm not really like a decorating the
house guy you know I was when the kids
were younger but now that they're all
like old people they don't care and uh
if I get invited to a party I will deal
with any but if I don't I'm perfectly
happy to sit at home and watch uh scary
movies all by myself did uh so have you
seen what the celebrities were doing for
Halloween particularly
uh I I pulled five
celebrity Halloween costumes
that we can we can chat about
uh the first and they're all wonderfully
nerdy and on brand for us
uh the first I'll put up is uh
Marge Simpson
let's see if you're looking at it can
you guess who that is
that
um
I want to say it's the woman from The
Marvelous Mrs maisel
you were looking at lizzo
that is lizzo yellow face lizzo went as
Marge Simpson for Halloween and
absolutely crushed it that is that is a
no [ __ ] amount of costume
uh my next uh one of my favorites let's
see if you can guess who this is
oh yeah it's uh that's John boyega it's
like easy John boyega is Easy E I
thought was wonderful it's the Jerry
curl that does it
uh this one uh I kind of I'm kind of
going in order I felt like this next one
is like these were the top five so we're
at number three right now
can you guess who was Mystique yes I
remember this story but Kim Kardashian
went to a Halloween party where nobody
else was in the costume with her
and I yeah I thought she yeah that's
pretty good uh then the last two I'm
gonna give number two
to
The Fifth Element for one reason have
you did you see this I did Janelle Monae
as the the the diva of Lost In Paradise
crushing that by far is the best costume
yeah but it also like looks the hardest
to get into yeah it looks like you get
that gets poured onto you oh man uh and
then did you see this story this story
was absolutely insane
our Joker our Heath Ledger Joker do you
know who that is
oh no
that
that is Diddy P Diddy Puff Daddy Sean
Combs
here's the thing
he had a flamethrower and a fake Tommy
Gun and it looked like he was walking up
and down Ventura Boulevard in the valley
and all of his real life like
people that follow him around everywhere
were dressed as clowns
and so he was doing like performance art
on Halloween
and I guess he got into a fight or
almost came to blows with uh Michael J
Ferguson
who's in uh the power show like there's
TMZ video of Diddy and him like in each
other's face because he didn't know who
it was anyway uh I so I wanted to point
those out because those I thought they
they brought it they were strong I mean
that's I suppose if you have a money and
B time
um and of course see desire then you can
kind of make almost anything come true
if you want to
um I am uh I have none of those three
okay yeah I uh I put on a floppy hat
with a net around it
and Jen hot glued bees to it and I went
as a beekeeper because Jocelyn went as a
little B oh that's so cute so but yeah I
all of those costumes look like white
well
I mean I couldn't do ECE but like that's
about the level of effort I think I
would put in too
a costume right like I got a hat
sunglasses you know a little Jerry curl
wig and some some black gear
like a video finding the LA Raiders
you know gear is probably the hardest
part
uh people in chat criticizing my hair
again thanks I killed Giants here's
here's the secret
uh this hair is three days old I have
headphones on so it's still sticking up
this much after sleeping on it for three
days so that's all right I didn't do my
hair for you Mark and I didn't do my
hair for the people of black man beyond
I apologize I'll try harder next time
that's all right neither of us did our
hair for a tonight's show so I think
we're okay
um sorry you were going somewhere I was
going
um
some finales we can talk about you know
even before we get to the new thing but
um and I I it has been long enough that
I may or may not have forgotten the
specifics of one of these finale's
um but rings of power and House of the
Dragon
they ended their freshman year uh you
know I uh I turned on um I turned on
both of them uh or I flipped on both of
them in that I started out really
enjoying rings of power and by the
finale
I had kind of felt
oh what's the nice way to say spoken
down to
meaning am I to believe if first off if
I'm watching rings of power
I have some basis in Tolkien
am I to believe that israeldor is dead
for three hours
do you really expect me to buy into that
that
con
and
you know his whole Arc in the show right
like writing 101 is where does the
person end up and where does your hero
end up and put him as far away from
there as possible to begin
so if he seal door is the guy who fails
he is the definition of the strength of
men failing and cannot throw the ring
into Mount Doom why do you make him a
[ __ ] up from from page one
because then when he throws doesn't
throw the ring in you're like oh of
course he doesn't throw the ring in he's
been a [ __ ] for the last five seasons
right he should have been Captain under
the guard Johnny on the spot Steve
Rogers level good and then each season
you give him a little bit of a you get a
little insight into his character flaw
so that when he doesn't throw the ring
in
Ed season five or whatever it's gonna be
which by the way spoilers for Lord of
the Rings that came out 80 years ago
when he doesn't throw it in you're
surprised by it you're like he's Captain
America how come he can't do the thing
and then you think back and you're like
oh I saw all the cracks that I don't buy
it Mordor
the reveal of Mordor being done by like
like a Fiverr level
graphic on screen
do you remember that where it's like the
Southlands flame up Mordor with like
the aerial or Times New Roman font
come on
and I'll tell you what the biggest
I loved Duran and uh
elrond throughout but for the most
expensive TV show of all time you think
you could have said it in the mines
where or the Great Hall where you know
we saw all of that stuff in Peter
Jackson's movies
and then you set it you set every
conversation save for one at at his
dining room table
come on
come on yeah I I'm with you on the on
the inside door stuff although I I had
so he is such like a third fourth tier
character in the show that are always
surprised me when they came around to
focusing any story on them because it
just this season didn't seem to be about
him at all but then I was like wait
you you cannot expect me to believe that
he's dead if I know anything about this
at all I know that he's not dead
you know and if I don't know anything
about this why do I care that this guy
that's in like five scenes in the show
has died you know like you you just been
invested in him at all and so the
weirdness of both of those things
happening was kind of odd
um I yeah I mean I I I dug the hey they
showed us the creation of Mordor that's
cool but yeah the weird like
um you know what the [ __ ] it's like it's
like an MTV show or something yeah but
like worse but worse
um I dug the I dug the Sauron reveal I
mean I thought they did that actually
very very nicely
um that like how could it possibly be
this guy except then they shave all the
ways that it totally is that God like
the the hiding and playing side of the
bad guy I thought it was pretty well
done
um although I don't know how that
dovetails with actual Canon
um but I also don't care to find out
because I'm just not that big of a
Tolkien nerd what about uh ethereal
Galadriel the daughter of The Shining
Light of the Stars who's just like you
know what
I'm not going to tell anybody that we
just made a bunch of powerful rings with
the guy I've been chasing around the
Middle Earth for 2 000 years I was like
like Peter Jackson
bill and I know I keep comparing it to
these movies that are Timeless Peter
Jackson built a special lighting rig to
light Kate Blanchette so she looks
uh like a goddess on Earth
uh
they didn't I mean they didn't even like
do the
woman's Roots every week on rings of
power and like rings of power season one
cost more than in F than one of Peter
Jackson's movies like it just
I don't know what I don't know
yeah I don't know they did you hear
they've paused they haven't started
shooting season two yet they've paused I
didn't hear that I mean I know they
moved from uh from New Zealand to the UK
um and I wonder if some of that has to
do with it but which also seems like a
weird
Choice other than maybe there's a bunch
of people that didn't want to be away
from their families for that long but
guys they have to go home I'm not going
to spend the next eight years
but um
but yeah I don't know I don't know what
that means
I don't know what that means
um and so you you said that you you
swapped your positions so how did you
feel about the end of the first season
of hot dude I got into it in that
uh
how should a dragon is essentially
nighttime soap opera right like that's
what we're watching
and they just made it really nighttime
soap opera like
renera lost her father lost her baby and
lost her second born in like 24 hours
like
that's like a soap opera that's like the
height of like a
a adult CW level
like schlocky thing and I'm I'm here for
it and then giant dragons on top of it
and
I don't know what the last one we talked
about was but like
you know you reveal that Damon is
actually
like you he earns his space back and
then he grabs her by the throat
I I think it's just fun
I think it's just fun now people dying
dragons eating people
I I it's just fun now
I uh I I think the the these last two
episodes
were for me probably the best of the
bunch
and yet they still
like there's these stretches in them
when I don't understand why people are
doing what they're doing
um
you know like even even though
um what's your name raynese the the
queen that never was
explains this wasn't by the water to
start
why like she had a chance to end
everything in this to strangle that
particular baby in the crib when she
shows up at the coronation with a dragon
and then just flies away like
it's and some of that is the scene like
it's why you set the scene the way you
said it if you didn't want her to do
that and I understand it because if the
show's over then have her still the
dragon from the dragon cave that doesn't
actually have to to come up into the and
and force a sunroof into this building
and kill a bunch of commoners in the
process like you're forcing that
confrontation to then not have a big
confrontation so then why are we getting
this scene at all
um you know like I I intellectually
understand why raylear is is bereft over
the death of her second born son
um but I had no idea who that child was
like I did when it's her kid but like
it's the fifth actor to play that
character yeah you know and like I don't
have a sense of who he is at all so when
she says you're the most like me but
really because I don't even know your
name
are you Jace or are you linked like
which which one of these kids from 90210
are you
this week because I couldn't tell you
um and I also didn't understand because
in we have had some select
um interactions with Dragons over the
course of our Game of Thrones uh careers
as viewers
um mostly in the TV show but also again
here and this is the first time they've
ever told us oh by the way dragons don't
always do what you tell them to do
you know like a little bit early every
other time somebody says a word that
Dragon blow smoke we want to rain fire
on this thing we can do it we're gonna
attack that ship we can do it we want to
fly alone in the red we're going to do
it we can fight another ice dragon we
let everything we've ever told a dragon
to do they've done it like obedient pets
except for this one time where two
dragons ignore everything that the
people tell them for reasons that don't
make any sense then now start a war and
like and if that's what if that's gonna
be where you finish the entirety of the
show
then I need just a little bit more
consistency in what I've come to know as
a viewer about how these horses operate
uh I agree with everything you said I
think that my expectations for House of
the Dragon are significantly lower
than what they are for building a
backstory to the best-selling book in
the history of Amazon which is the Lord
of the Rings perhaps
yeah no I get it I mean they're they're
both they're both aiming for a different
Gap
um I'm not sure either one hits that
depth
um to to see the liberally from Harry
stamper in on the game
um we can hit the depth trust me
we hit the death Raymond
um but like I just because it didn't
feel as if rings of power was trying to
be deep it didn't bother me that it
wasn't
whereas House of the Dragon always felt
like it was just trying to be the most
serious thing in the world
um and and proceeded as if I was
emotionally invested in it even if they
never did quite enough to get me there
um even though like every scene in and
of itself is a well done safe you know
like all the performances are good even
at writings within their scenes are good
scene work is strong but
it just maybe it's maybe it's a side
effect of the time jumps maybe it's a
side effect of all of the recast on
these but
um
I'm not entirely sure you couldn't have
just started this show like four or five
episodes in
um when everybody is the age they're
supposed to be and then sort of live
deeper in that part of the story yeah
but that's that is that is the height of
armchair quarterbacking
and so all I'll say is you know I'll
tune in for next year
um because of course I will but I uh I
was not I was not blown away by this
first season of either one shows yeah I
uh it's got I'll tell you what part of
House of the Dragon for me also is that
Jen and I watch it together
um so it's like our one little thing
that we do each week and we made the
time for and
watching the last couple episodes I was
like because we're gonna go back and
watch Game of Thrones now because she's
really into into this and she watches
she loves it because she watches like
Virgin River on Netflix and and like uh
sweet Magnolias and all of that type of
soap opera without dragons and so we're
gonna go back and watch Game of Thrones
and what I realized is like one of the
biggest moments for Game of Thrones of
me was when
I think it was Drogo came down when
Daenerys was surrounded and was gonna
get killed and she climbs on his back
and flies away and that's like the first
time I have never read the book so I
don't know anything but it was like the
first time you even ever even imagined
that she could ride a dragon and escaped
and it was like one of the Pinnacle
parts of that show for me and I looked
at Jen and I was like oh that's not
gonna mean anything to you because
everybody rides dragons whether you've
got
white hair or not you can ride a dragon
uh yeah you know it's like this this is
a show about we have all of these nukes
and we're not sure what to do with them
and Game of Thrones is like we have one
of them
we managed to find a nuke in the middle
of nowhere wait there's three of them
and only this one lady can control them
this is bananas
whereas it's like you can just get a
dragon from a used car lot if you can
sing the right song to it
uh yeah I don't know I'll watch them
both next time out yeah but
yeah
um and are you you are not caught up on
Android correct I am not
um but man I I really love
mon mothman's shitty home life
and I really love uh
I love the beach beach party Jam uh at
the end of episode seven where he's like
walking on the beach with his money like
you get a glimpse of what Han Solo
intended to do with the money he got
from the Rebellion at the end of Star
Wars before like his conscience
Chewbacca was like
you better turn around
uh
man that was amazing I just that song
I was just like this is what it would be
like to be on like
you know
MTV Spring break in Star Wars like you'd
be listening to this trance music on the
this Beach planet for the Florida of
Star Wars
complete with over aggressive policing
yeah
um yeah I'm I'm caught up I'm fully
caught up
um and you know without spoiling
anything I will say that the show is
playing the longest of long games
um with its characters and like every
time you think that we've left somebody
behind it finds a way to re-engage with
a character and and specifically with
the serial character who like we meet in
the very first episode it's like the
best idiots young you know not even
Imperial officer because he's just part
of that private company that's running
that you know ferrics I guess
um but through his sort of defrocking
and it's just disgracing and all that
stuff as he's finding trying to clock
his way back into the good graces of the
people in charge you know just watching
him watching that level of desperation
um is uh is is pretty great
um
and yeah like we are inside an imperial
I would call it a prison because it it
feels more like it's a Work Camp
um even though it's all interior and it
all feels like THX 1138 they're not
gonna aggressively designed kind of
milky white institutional space but it's
just it's so lived in every little
detail makes sense every character is
doing a thing for a reason
um
yeah you know I've spoken to friends and
as I mentioned that you have as well who
do sort of
say like listen it's very good it's just
not Star Wars
and uh
and I don't know what to tell you man
I mean it's as Star Wars as
the Cantina scene I mean I guess the
Cantina scene has a lightsaber in it but
like
you know I I don't know I don't think
you need fantasy or mysticism for
something to be Star Wars
uh I'll tell you what
the two things that I really loved is
one I think it was episode six
uh where they they steal the money
is that the idealistic young rebel guy
who is like you know the heart
and soul of what the Rebellion stands
for
I loved that he got crushed and died by
a giant sled full of money
like like but you know it's like that
little detail that they don't point out
in dialogue
[Music]
um
and uh
and I'm on the edge of my seat like I
know spoilers Cassie and Andor dies
five minutes before the beginning of
Star Wars A New Hope
and spoilers The Rebellion wins but I'm
still on the edge of my seat each week
watching
how they're going to do it and what how
it's gonna get done
um yeah which is wild
yeah I mean I love that the entire
perspective of this show is the good
guys are going to make it shitty for
everyone because we cannot have a
rebellion until the Imperial overreach
is so excessive and the brutality is so
extreme we need a thing to rebel against
and we're too comfortable like if you if
like over time you can get used to just
about everything and so the entire you
know the theft that aldani was not about
we need money
to put on the Rebellion it's like a
lovely side effect but instead it's we
need the Empire to crack down on people
so that they ruin their [ __ ] lives so
that when we decide to start recruiting
everybody has a reason to pick up a gun
and fight and that is some nihilistic
[ __ ] right there but like yeah I get it
you know that's how you fight a
bureaucracy
you know something that um
the argument that I make with people who
are like this and or is not Star Wars
because of what it is
I think
the Mandalorian is
spiritually the thing that is the
successor to Return of the Jedi right it
takes away Return of the Jedi left off
and continues down that path
but I think if George Lucas was 25 years
old today
and or is the show that would become
What A New Hope is
meaning you know Star Wars is a
has a commentary on
coming out of a very
uh historically dark time you know after
the Kennedy assassination and uh and
um Vietnam and you know every movie that
was out like your sci-fi was 2001 your
your best picture movies were Taxi
Driver like nothing there was no hope
and then they make a New Hope whereas
now where
good guys aren't so cut and dry we don't
really know what's going on who to trust
our neighbors are
maybe not who we thought they were I
think andor's honestly the show that a
young George Lucas would have made today
so I think Andor is more
in line what new star what Star Wars did
for society in
1977 I feel like Andor is more in line
with that for 2022 than like
the Mandalorian giving us Luke Skywalker
killing things with a green lightsaber
which I love but I don't think it has
the same
relevance Beyond
uh I've been waiting to see that for 38
years
and I do think to your point you know
it is not it does not go unnoticed that
Star Wars was a always about a rebellion
and B always about fascism and tyranny
and see even before he made his tweaks
to it like Han Solo was killing people
like on shot first you guys I don't care
how many times they try and take that
out of my Mutant like that's who that
guy was and and it's in great part of
why we loved him you know and so you
know Cassie and Angela and Han Solo are
not cut from too different to cloth
um at the end of the day just cassian's
life was more difficult going into it
and also you guys Han Solo used to be
like an imperial pilot
he he used to be one of the bad guys
and decided that he found a different
path to follow
um it was always I'm not even saving
money it was very clear about its
perspective and its politics
um and it was always you know
uh punching up at Power
um as opposed to pushing down at people
in need and so like
today that show is incredibly relevant
as it was in 1970s five or four whenever
the first idea came into Georgia's head
um I mean so yeah it's it is spiritually
as Star Wars as anything
you think I mean like people like George
Lucas did Star Wars because he didn't
want to risk his life to go make
Apocalypse Now
I mean Lucas was set to direct
Apocalypse Now
indeed Star Wars you know like he was
that guy back then
um so yeah I I haven't seen episode
eight but I am
Beyond Blown Away by the quality of that
show and it's
huge it is huge the show looks every
three episodes should be could be a
movie it doesn't feel
small it it feels bigger than both House
of the dragon and rings of power
yeah because it feels like they went to
places and Shop there
um and then designed the [ __ ] out of a
spaces that they have every bit of lived
in reality in in ways that yeah I mean
you can do a lot on on a volume you can
do a whole tunnel with CG and I'm sure
there are a whole mess of CG
enhancements going on at Endor but it
just it feels like you're actually
[ __ ] bare when they're in the the
hills of Scotland
um you know pretending to be the Bluffs
of valdani I believe they're in that
[ __ ] mud you know like when they go
to Coruscant I believe that you know
we're in the ghettos of course huh like
that's pretty [ __ ] great
yeah it's so good it's so good I I feel
like
I don't know I feel like it's the Star
Wars I've been waiting for my whole life
um I feel like it's my adult Star Wars
versus Mandalorian is like my like if
you take the Nostalgia out of
Mandalorian and I love Mandalorian so
don't like crucify me bro and I love the
Mandalorian but like
like if Luke Skywalker isn't the guy
that shows up if it's some Rando and if
that woman doesn't whisper thrawn to
Ahsoka at somebody else like
you just don't care
like it it is it is all of the weight of
that show and all of the anticipation
comes from the fact that I grew up
watching Boca tan
and now she's here versus like
building I mean they do a very good job
with Mando but like
everything around that is predicated on
Nostalgia and and the fact that you grow
up and you love this stuff where an
Andor it's like I've never seen this
part of course on but like here we are
you know
like it just yeah I mean so good
I think I you know when we first started
talking about Mandalorian on the podcast
um you know I think I if you were to go
back and listen to those First episodes
I was a bit crestfallen because it did
feel kind of juvenile you know and then
I came around to you know remember any
Star Wars is that it has always been for
children
um and so the fact that it feels like
it's a bit kid-family
um I can't hold it against it you know
and I and I did eventually come around
to especially when you introduce like
not getting and stuff it's like this
first season actually got very strong I
could end it incredibly well
um and it ended in a way that it stood
on its own feet that that it that it
earned its Drama by the time we got to
the end it was not an it wasn't really a
Nostalgia play yet
um it was just other than we like to be
in this world and we like to hear laser
beams and we like to to see a guy in a
Mando outfit cloth and do some cool ship
as the Boba Fett we always wish we got
you know and then in season two when it
began to engage deeper with its own
Nostalgia and then you begin to
introduce you know these characters that
had been you know Luke Skywalker and
look at the time after Circle time and
all that stuff
looks like it's cool but now it's less
the mandom show and it's more
you know a Jedi
1.5
you know and so the more it began to
engage in nostalgia in a very little way
the the sort of
it the the the the pleasures got to be
somewhat cheap you know what I mean it's
it's like oh yeah I'm gonna do I'm gonna
do a shot of this cheap liquor that is
going to get me buzzed as opposed to
drink this really good wine
that like holy [ __ ] I didn't even know
that I was buzzed but I'm loving this
like the the gentle but impactful drug
of earning it as opposed to this has a
lot of proof
yeah I don't and here's the thing and
I've said it maybe on the show weeks ago
but like
I think that had I not gotten
The Nostalgia bomb that I get from the
favro filoni Universe I probably would
be more bitter towards and or because
I'd be like why are you giving me this
when all I want to see is Luke Skywalker
the green lightsaber you know why aren't
you scratching the itch that the sequel
Trilogy didn't scratch you have a chance
to do it that's all any of us want to
see
but since I got that and I will continue
to get that
and or's wonderful in how different it
is
yeah yeah it's not a corrective it's a
contrast
you know it's you know I I think if
there's if there's anything corrective
about it it's oh you can make IP based
content that is as well wrought and well
executed as this you do not have to
suffer quality
um in any phase of production
um simply because it's based on a movie
or another TV show or whatever
um but I'm I'm I am to your point glad
that they both exist and glad that there
is a grown-up Star Wars for people
who've liked Star Wars since they were
kids in addition to the Star Wars that
makes you feel like you were a kid
mm-hmm
um
so yeah I think that's
that's the end of the we saw some [ __ ]
and we want to talk about it oh I get we
can touch on tales of the Jedi real
quick too oh that's right that's right
that's right uh tales of the Jedi which
is a thing that I don't think you know
in a world where the moment somebody has
a thought they announce it with a
release date uh tales of the Jedi kind
of like
creeped up on us
um
I binge watched it in two sittings I
watched three and then the back three
um
you watched the first two I've seen the
first two I saw the the baby Ahsoka
episode and I saw the first of what
apparently the three Dooku episodes
um and you and I both because we talked
about it before the show I think we both
felt the same about the first two
episodes
yeah I mean I I didn't understand
I didn't understand why we we told the
Ahsoka story
um because it doesn't add anything to
her character you're not exploring
anything it's just there's a kid and
somebody says oh she's going to be a
Jedi and then that's why a tiger didn't
eat her
um which you know it's cute but uh
beyond the cuteness I don't know I don't
know what the the dramatic initiative
was behind it
yeah I
um I watched the show Saturday night and
Sunday morning so it had been out for
five days or four days and I saw it
all range of Star Wars fans loved it
nine out of ten the people who hate
Mandalorian and 9 out of 10 the people
who love Last Jedi 9 out of ten the
people who hate Last Jedi 9 out of ten I
was like wow this is gonna be
this has got to be really good and then
I watched the first two episodes and I
was like
well baby Ahsoka is cute
and like young Dooku's kind of a dick
uh
and then
episodes
the rest of it
the rest of it does what Dave filoni
does so well which is uh if you trace
Count Dooku
from the moment he
uh you see he's rebellious and you see
that his Padawan is Qui-Gon Jinn
and then you see that in episode one
Qui-Gon Jinn is rebellious and you get
to watch
the arrogance of the Jedi
radicalize Count Dooku to join forces
with
Sidious
uh
because he thinks that's the best way to
um keep the Jedi from
you know going down the same path
um
The Count Dooku stories I think make
episodes one and two better
and that's something I think Dave
filoni's done a lot with all the
animated stuff he's done is he looks
where
there may have been shortcomings in
things that make sense or stories that
we've gotten from George Lucas
and added context I don't want to say
retcon because that sounds bad but he
adds context to what's already there
uh that makes it more enjoyable
um
what I thought was interesting is the
last two episodes
are all about Ahsoka and you haven't
seen Clone Wars through
the end of Cl the end of Clone Wars
Ahsoka essentially becomes
Superman at a point and does some
absolutely insane stuff and I think that
Dave probably it's fun but it's a little
ridiculous even for a cartoon I think
Dave probably got some Flack for that
and you you get an episode of this that
you think is just
it's Anakin training Ahsoka and you
think it's like oh this is fun we're
getting Ashley X Stein and Matt Lanter
and uh TC Carson and James Arnold Taylor
and all these voice actors it's like the
reunion special this is a reason to get
them all back in the same room
uh and then at the end it ends that
episode ends where
this the like last Ahsoka scene of Clone
Wars picks up
and all of a sudden you realize why
she's particularly well suited to
her Superman like showing in that show
uh so I loved that Dave has spent
God since 2007 or eight
adding context to George Lucas Star Wars
and then with this he was able to go
back and add context to
Dave filoni Star Wars that he made after
George was out
um
I do appreciate I appreciate that it
seems like
so much of his Star Wars work if not the
overwhelming majority of it is like a
people Reclamation project
right like he loves them
um you know somewhat unabashed and wants
all of us to love them as much as he
does and so devoted to you know however
long it's been 10 years of his life
to telling stories that fill in the gaps
that that are taken in total suddenly
turned what had been something a little
bit ramshackled into this kind of
operatic piece
um that that introduces new players and
charts wise and Falls clear rising and
falling clear
um
that finds the finds the drama that was
inherent but not explicit and makes it
explicit you know and then characters
that you may or may not have have had
any real fondness for he makes them
beloved and then characters that have
been you know beloved in in Clone Wars
is then bring them to live action so now
they can stand and and take place in the
same medium in the Canon the same way
that everything else does like I I
appreciate that from a deep nerd
perspective
um I just haven't gone down the road
with him as far as he's gone yet
it's uh well yeah I guess the
the rumor or maybe it's confirmed is
that Dave wrote These on a plane
like he just had the idea and he sat
down and wrote him and that's also what
was super interesting is you know Dave
filoni is the head creative guy at
lucasfilm now
uh working on Ahsoka
custodian of the live action everything
um you know if you pay attention he
hasn't touched lucasfilma animation in
years he's kind of the executive
producer but different directors
different writers he was
four of the fir he was three of the
first four credits was executive
produced by Dave filoni then it was
George Lucas then it was directed by
Dave filoni and
something else by Dave filoni and then
he wrote all of them
so this was definitely like his
his world and his kind of return to Star
Wars animation after
kind of handing the reins over to I
think the guy's name is Brad I don't
remember Brad something
um so that was kind of cool to see him
kind of go back to his roots there also
yeah no I mean I'll I will finish them
out I just there's
once once you mentions oh I've seen them
all like I completely forgot that they
had dropped
um because I had been in such like
indoor mode
um and then was that the uh was it the
Austin Film Festival this past weekend
um not with Splinter I was just there as
a as a speaker and as a workshop
participant
um which was lovely my first time in the
Austin Film Festival which is a very
very deep focus on screen lighting and
screenwriters
um so it's sort of nice to to be part of
that little circus for a little bit
um but it did completely spaced that
there was a new space thing that I
should have watched
and they also dropped him all at once
which is a very undisney plus thing to
do yeah yeah
um but thankfully they did because if
they hadn't I think you would have seen
a lot of people just be like uh
18 minutes long yeah I'll also say
it is the prettiest animation and best
sound design of it could have been I
mean they all could have been it was
movie quality
uh stuff especially the Ahsoka episode I
was like I don't know why I'm watching
this but it's really pretty
um also all right well that's that's all
the stuff that I think uh between me and
Batman we have seen
um in the last uh in the last bit I
could go deeper again on interview the
vampire other but I won't other to say
it's still very very good it still might
be one of my favorite things on TV
um
to watch
and I'm still I'm caught up I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm I'm on the week of the walking
dead because after making that my
pandemic binge on all 10 seasons of it
um I am I'm going to see it through I am
a man of my word hey I finish things
yeah
um
and so yeah once we get to finale I will
get to talk about that too
um but
that means we are done with the uh the
catching up Chit Chat that's what the
review portion of stuff we've seen
um now we're going to dip into the news
um but before we do that I am going to
talk about getting your dick hard
yeah I am
um the other sponsor for this evening uh
this evening's uh episode of black man
beyond are the good Folks at Bluetooth
Who deliver them to me my favorite ad
copy to me so
the nights are getting longer but the
breeze isn't the only thing that's
getting stiff that's right this episode
is sponsored by blush guys we all know
the confidence can take you from my life
that's especially true in the bedroom
especially when it's time to step up to
the plate and that's where Bluetooth
comes in Bluetooth is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can take them anytime day
or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple so either
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
is it's all done on lives you know
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line
with the pharmacy so
if you could benefit from a little extra
confidence when it's time to perform
chew it and do it have better sex with
Bluetooth and we've got a special deal
for a deal for our listeners to try
Bluetooth free when you use our promo
code fat Mana checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code Fatman to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and as always we thank Bluetooth for
sponsoring this podcast
so
some news
um let's see since there's not another
dude to debate this with this is it's
not going to take another one in a long
time so we're just going to kind of
um batter through some stuff and and
talk about them as we see fit
so first
um there is from uh executive producerin
right here Brian Fuller
um a new Friday the 13th prequel series
coming after years of speculation the
Friday the 13th franchise is finally
back on its feet
um thanks to the good folks
um behind Hannibal and also American
Gods
um peacock has officially greenlit
Crystal Lake
um a prequel series based on the
franchise to be written and executive
produced by Brian Fuller while exact
plot details will be equipped Under
Wraps this will Mark the first Friday
the 13th project since a lawsuit between
director Sean Cunningham and the
screenwriter Victor Miller was seemingly
settled last year uh it's coming from
the folks at 824 who know their way
around horror
um and according to uh Fuller I
discovered five the Friday the 13th and
the pages of famous Monsters magazine
when I was 10 years old and I've been
thinking about this story ever since
when it comes to heart a24 raises the
bar and pushes the envelope and I'm
thrilled to be exploring the campgrounds
of Crystal Lake under their Banner
uh I am if you've been to my uh my
Twitter page uh you can see that my name
my Halloween name was Mark horror was
Bernardo because I have a heart was but
I have seen Friday 13th
um and so getting to talk about
um what led up to the events that shut
down on Camp Crystal Lake to begin with
uh it seems like a smart way to go
um and Brian Fuller um is a dude who
knows his way around things that go up
at night so I'm curious
I'll give it a go we'll see what's what
um in other news
um the Great and Powerful and
awe-inspiring Yaya Abdul Mateen II is
taking on Disney's Wonder Man coming off
some of the best reviews of his career
for his work in Broadway's Revival of
the political prize winning play Top Dog
Underdog Yaya is preparing to move from
DC to Marvel at the lead for the studios
Wonderland TV show
um let's see the live action series was
first announced back in June with Destin
Daniel [ __ ] who directed Sean Chi
um and Hawkeye co-producer Andrew guest
announcing their involvement
um [ __ ] will direct and second
produced with guest servings the head
writer
it will also feature the return of Ben
kingsley's Trevor Slattery
um the supervillains here a good guy or
not super guy
um who has been uh first seen as the
Mandarin but totally not the Mandarin
what was in both Iron Man 3 and Sean Chi
um and uh yeah yeah Abdul Mateen was in
most recently
um of course the Watchman he was in um
he was playing Morpheus in The Matrix
resurrections he will be once again back
as Black Manta and Aquaman and the lost
kingdom which will be out on December
25th 2023
you know I I dig it he he like right
next to Jonathan Majors is one of the
more exciting young actors to kind of uh
make the make a splash the last 10 years
or so and I'll watch whatever this dude
does because he's good at everything he
was even good in The Matrix and that
movie is awful
um
so and it's not his fault so yeah man
I'm here for it you know I'm here for
I'm here for the cruise there's Wonder
Man both choirs charisma
so yeah man down down to Cleveland
um speaking of clowns not a great segue
but um they've cast Sophia Falcone in
the penguin show
um but Matt Reeves is making a spin-off
TV series from the Batman
um Colin Farrell is again playing the
Penguin and now Kristin miliati uh is
playing um Sophia Falcone she's a
daughter of Carlisle Falcon of course
was played by Johnson tour in the movie
and she is in this series will be
battling with the penguin over control
of Gotham City
um yeah you know casting stuff always
cool
um I like her as an actress
um she was very funny in Palm Springs
um and funny is not all that she was but
it was it was a pretty great performance
in uh in that Adam
from I don't know go with my Brave I
want to say Adam Sandler with the show
no no no no Andy Samberg
I'm sorry
I don't know what happened Adam Sandler
Andy Samberg I mean I'm not that far off
right but anyway she's very good in
Oxford I quite like that
um so yeah I'll tune in we'll see what's
what
um
as captains always feel like the
beginning of a project sadly every now
and again and we have to announce the
end of one and Star Girls light is faded
um uh the DC uh CW Show currently in the
middle of its third season
um which will be his last season
um you know it starred created by Jeff
Johns
um stars Brett Bassinger previous guest
of its podcast about the first show when
the first season was premiering as high
school student Courtney Whitmore
um who began as a as a character but
Jeffrey Johnson created back in 1999
inspired by his sister who died
tragically in a 1996 plane crash
um the cancellation of star girl
I don't think reflects in any way the
quality of the show as much as it
reflects that the CW has been sold to a
batch of new owners uh next star Media
Group which has been canceling quite a
few things um Riverdale is coming to the
end of its it's run as is the flash of
Nancy Drew
um it seems as if maybe that this is not
superheroic storytelling is not what
they want to offer the CW any longer
um but you know take some Solace that
the writing staff was all told I'm
relatively early that uh this season
would be the last so they were able to
do fashion and ending for the series
that will make some sense
um and I think the final episode will be
coming in early December
um so if you were a fan uh I'm sorry to
to hopefully not bring back the
Instagram I hope that you've discovered
it before now but at the very least
um you will get an ending that feels
like an ending as opposed to it we just
stopped here that's weird we've all
watched those shows that just got
canceled far earlier than they should
have and which is the last episode of
the last episode
um
um speaking of castings and endings
um
on the heels of Henry Campbell
um sort of unveiling his initiative and
his desire to return as the man of steel
and DC movies and then perhaps in
conjunction with the announcement that
guy Richie is making a film called the
ministry of a gentlemanly Warfare about
spies during World War II of which
Campbell will be playing the lead
um he is stepping away from The Witcher
um the fourth season will find a Gerald
of Rivia being played by Liam Hemsworth
um
you will get one more season with
capital
um which uh which will return next
summer
um and then there's also approval um the
Richer blood origin which launches this
uh Christmas fact this year
um but uh but yeah there's there's a
lovely a lovely little statement you
know my journey is Gerald geralt Gerald
I'm gonna say Gerald maybe uh I'm going
to watch the show but I just don't
remember
has been filled with both monster and
adventure and allowance I will be laying
down my downloaded my swords for season
four and I said The Fantastic Mr Liam
Hemsworth will be taking up the mantle
of the white wolf as with the greatest
and literary characters I pass the
course with reverence for the time spent
in Bobby and Gerald and enthusiasm to
see Liam's take on this Most Fascinating
and nuanced of men Liam good sir his
character has such a wonderful depth to
him enjoy that again and seeing what you
can find
um according to sources Cavill had made
a short-term deal for The Witcher and he
just felt like it was time to move on
after three seasons on the show Which
films over season has a pretty demanding
production schedule
um so I don't know if there's it doesn't
sound like there's any animosity going
on there but just yeah you know you're
gonna have to get used to a new guy
um grunting his way through a fantasy
landscape and stabbing everything inside
real quick real quick I saw um
a Photoshop of Liam Hemsworth
face on The Witcher Henry cavill's
Witcher character and it was it looked
wonderful so I don't watch the show but
I don't think you're gonna get tripped
up by like well he looks so different
now
anyway that's all I have to say on that
you put a wig in it and then some
stubble on a guy you know and you spend
a Godly amount of time in the gym you
can probably make that work
um
in other news and our final news item of
the day
um there is a vision TV series that
works for Marvel TV
um this second one division spin-off
um we'll focus on Paul Bentley's
character titled Vision Quest
um which is opening a writer's room this
week I believe is about Vision trying to
regain his memory Humanity allegedly and
while the focus is on a vision of course
there's the possibility that won the
maximum will appear
um given how closely connected those two
characters are
um it's being overseen by uh the one
division Creator writer executive
producer Jack shaper who's also
overseeing Agatha
um
Covenant of something or other house of
Awesomeness um whatever they're called
that show
um
so yeah I mean listen I love Paul
Bettany as that character
um I think that there's there's always
there's always potential in a story
about a rule about wanting to be a real
boy
and it seems as if the ongoing Vision
project is somewhat pinocchio-ish which
uh which feels pretty good
um especially given that Marvel is so
much about the humanity of their
character so what better than you have a
character who's not human on his quest
to become so
um
and uh and while I didn't love the
entirety of of One Division I mean we
spoke about it on the bud you know we
then talked about it with uh with the
director Matt shackman when he hopped on
for a season
um I do think that the white Vision
Vision stuff you know the ship of
Theseus argument all of that was was a
fascinating
um beat in that finale and so if this is
going to be more philosophical uses of a
of a white Android
um here for it happy for it
um
so there you have it boys and girls damn
hey do you think
so
I probably shouldn't say this when we
when we had shackman on the show he
texted me to like coordinate so I have
his cell phone number should I text him
in like two years
and see if he'll do
uh Fantastic Four with us
absolutely you should he'll be like who
is this I'll be like please
[Music]
all right we had fun and you liked us
you liked us
uh yeah so I'll try it once Fantastic
Four wraps I'll I'll just I'll go Direct
why the hell not you know or you could
all be you could be the [ __ ] who does
it every week from now until then
hey man how's it going all right it's
Grandma next this morning how about you
don't forget us
you want to just give us a production
how how'd page seven and eight go of the
script writing today good
yeah yeah so uh still four four people
right no yeah you're not adding up there
no okay just making sure
okay bye
so yeah all right we'll try that
cool cool cool
um well before you run away man do we
have any q a today or are we are we done
with the podcast
um we got a couple uh a couple questions
that I pulled when I'm talking which I
did more than I ever have on this show I
can't I can't do two things at once
anymore
I missed a lot of the chat I can't do
two things at once it's gone
um but I did pull a couple questions uh
first one from uh Brayden gosy
uh who we've gotten some other questions
from he said uh
if you could serve in any role in
Starfleet what would it be
any rolling Starfleet ooh
um
I mean like that's the weirdest part
about Starfleet you know the weirdest
part about life in the Federation
is that you know and I remember talking
about this over the weekend with um
with with a fellow named Beau de Mayo or
demaio I think he's Divine
um who was a writer on Star Trek uh
strange new worlds
um and so we we for some reason got
talking about the Federation and
Starfleet and how none of it really
makes sense from a how you can keep a
civilization going they're like oh yeah
there's no money but but I don't
understand how wait what everybody can
do whatever they want to do but what
happens when you need people to do
things that they don't want to do like
not everybody wants to
take out the garbage not everybody wants
to to work in the sewers of Utopia
Plantation shipyards somebody has to
um and so how do you incentivize them to
do that if you don't pay them money
because that's also not somebody's
greatest life's dream like I get for
your treatment to be the captain of the
Starship nobody wants to like scrub the
inside of a giant toilet bowl
um so without money how does that happen
we couldn't crack it
um but Starfleet I guess is different
from the Federation like a star Fleet is
like you join the Navy right so like
what's your job going to be in the Navy
are you going to be an enlisted person
are you going to want to be an officer
or do you want to go in navigation or
command or or engineering or you know
counseling
um
you know or do you want to be like a
civilian contractor who just comes in
and uh and works on the the ships and
and the buildings and then goes back to
your life
feel like
um
I'm not a military person by Nature
and so the desire to go to an academy
and the desire to do all that training
and all that stuff doesn't excite me so
much
um
but I would I think I'd want to be a
historic
you know like I think I'd want to be the
chronicler of the adventures that
Starfleet goes on I think I want to be
the guy who's
um doing the research and discovering
the stories that nobody's heard of all
of these civilizations that we've made
first contact with that we've invited
into the Federation
um you know and it seems like there
might be a place for that person on
every Starship right like you're gonna
go into the into the middle of nowhere
is the great wide open and encounter
strange new worlds and and strange new
civilizations
um somebody should be there to tell
their story somebody should be there to
to write down their Legends someone
should be there to to absorb the that
the emotional data that comes with with
Legends
um and I think that might be an
interesting job
I think that might be a fulfilling job
as a person who does not want to
um you know
launch a phaser fuselage against a bad
guy's ship as much as like can I just
hang on the bar and like interview
people about their lives and like Gannon
will bring me over some delicious actual
alcohol and we can just we can just tell
stories or underwear on fire that sounds
great
yeah that sounds awesome I think I'd
want to be one of those guys that sits
like the judges the judges everybody
because I don't like people telling me
what to do
it doesn't seem like anybody can tell
those people what to do no
yeah you want to be on like the high
tribunal of something
I'm just like not real successful it
with longevity in working for other
people
so I feel like if I was a Starfleet
captain and there were then there was an
admiral and the Admiral is always poking
me to go left when I want to go right it
wouldn't end well
not for me not for him not for Starfleet
it's a goddamn reichenberg
um all right uh
hobbies for hire
uh what's one character you would like
to see debut in live action in Andor
after we just got done talking for an
hour about how happy we are there's no
nostalgia in Andor
who's one character you'd like to see
I mean it's it's tough because
so much of my
um my Star Wars is not
based in and around the animated stuff
you know like I I
as I've said more than once including
today like I've seen you know some of
the first two seasons of Clone Wars I
probably watched the first four or five
episodes of rebels but because
it wasn't a Clone Wars kid it didn't
quite sink in the same way
first first five episodes of rebels
don't sink in the same way or what no
matter what you do that's a fight to get
to the end of that first season then it
gets really good yeah
um but I think you know
I I think as you as you scale up the way
that show works and it seems as if we
are never really going to be about
encountering Jedi
um
and I don't necessarily want to but I
think that there is some version of as
the ISB begins to feed up to the Empire
at large as it becomes to feet up to you
know you you start to climb these these
ladders
um I mean maybe there is a you know
Lieutenant Commander thrawn that you can
meet who is who is yet not yet ascended
to like vice admiral or whatever he is
you know like everybody's gonna start
selling like where does that guy start
and how for all I know
Cyril who is this character on an Andor
you know like I don't know where throck
gets his blue skin from I don't know if
that's a space accident
it's probably not a space accident but
I'll say it anyway
um he's like a mood ring when he says it
turns blue when he's mad he turns red
maybe it's a good alien species
see he always he can always tell what
the the the the tenor of the room is
you know or maybe just use too many
blueberries space blueberries and then
he turns blue like uh like with a walker
I um
there is a character
that
has kind of existed in books and legends
and everywhere for a very long time
and he was in the deleted scenes of
Return of the Jedi I believe
um and he's never been as far as I know
I don't think he's ever been animated or
live action at least not with any
speaking lines
um and it's somebody named General
Kraken and he is supposed to be
like
he's like the head of Rebel intelligence
he's like always the sharpest guy in the
room
uh he's the guy who knows what's going
on
um he's kind of like the guy
I always pictured him a lot like
stellen or the Skarsgard is it stellen
in the in Andor his character
the way he looks and holds himself or
um in and or or in Rogue one the guy who
like calls out Jen erso and he's like uh
Leanna holic or should I call you jyn
urso like that guy is kind of like
General Kraken is he's portrayed but
like I'd like him that actual character
to show up
in the show and
I think he'd slide in really well as
like the
Rebel intelligence boss who's not afraid
to uh put some bodies behind him
that's cool
that's cool no I'd be there for that I'd
be there for that
five people who know what I'm talking
about but they're very excited
yeah it is it is the the
side effect of my lack of Engagement
with the uh the uh extended Universe the
expanded universe of Star Wars lore is
that I come pretty much right from the
uh I'm on the main vein
not in any tributaries
um all right but that was a good one
that was a good one
um
we got a good one to bring us home
uh yeah I think it's gonna be difficult
but we'll try it okay uh digital puppets
asks if you and Mark could rewrite the
ending of any film which film would you
pick and how would you rewrite it
if I could reread the ending of any
movie
I'll go I know what I would do
okay
shoot I'm not sure exactly what I would
do but I would rewrite the ending to the
first Wonder Woman movie
and I think I would have it and
I'd probably just take like the last 20
minutes off because I thought that movie
was so fantastic and bright and hopeful
and
the antithesis to the Giant
uh amber and gray Dark Cloud that is
everything from that era of DC
um right up until Aries shows up and
then it's a void of them on a Tarmac
with black and Amber clouds all around
them
uh throwing giant tanks at each other
in a in a fight that just doesn't matter
I think I would have it and
with her
and St and Steve Trevor I'd have it end
like right around that that part of the
show I don't think we even need to see
Aries I think the the ending of that
show is Wonder Woman realizes that
uh
you know she has her moment there uh
before she needs to
to destroy Ares in a weird
cloud of smoke or I would have her win
by not fighting physically
that she uses the things that she
learned from the the humans or the
people on Earth to defeat Ares in a
smarter way not a Punchy way
yeah I hear that
I hear that
um
I think I I go I think I'd like to take
another whack at the ending of Thor
Logan attack
um
you know I I think that that the movie
it wants to have it both ways
specifically with Gore the god butcher
who does not butcher nearly enough Gods
to be going to God bless you
um but they want us to take him legit
seriously as a threat
um and as a villain
um but it also does kind of bend over
backwards to give him the somewhat
redeeming finale
um where like the bad guy gets his wish
to come true and your good guys don't
um and it's not that I have a problem
with Jane Foster spoiler alert
um dying from the cancer that she's been
avoiding for that long but if
everybody's going to make it to the
place where wishes can come true
um
I would almost rather it be that like
Jane does have a wish that she wants to
come true but it has nothing to do with
with her living any longer
um you know I think that there's some
version of wanting Thor
I don't know it's also not a movie that
feels like it's about him learning to
take responsibility for anybody else
um
so I just
if you're going to do that kind of
ending
um then I think that everybody who
crosses that that Rubicon should get a
thing to come true for them and for
Thor's big lesson is to have to raise
Gore's daughter as his own
it just didn't seem to remind me of very
much of anything it didn't seem to
harmonize with very much of anything
but if it was you have to raise I need
those son as your own
um because Hondo was your best friend
who died sending you away so that you
can then survive and going to kill
Thanos and this kid has been left in
orphan and you haven't been able to
engage with it because you've been off
gallivanting around the universe doing
[ __ ] Thor [ __ ]
and then he gets kidnapped by the bad
guy because you were not on your watch
doing what he should have been doing and
if James dying wishes for him to learn
to be that person that he needs to be
um to have seen in that child what you
know he also saw in his father
I mean I'm I'm spinning it now only
because you asked for that question so
so that's the answer but I I was kind of
um you know emotionally unfulfilled by
the ending of that film
um and I think that there's a version of
it
that does get you
um more emotion and
you would have had to sort of treat that
cancer you know with a little bit more
gravity and weight
um but
but yeah I think just another another
whack at the way that movie resolves
where I don't need to feel pathos for
the bad guy
um like we're gonna kill the bad guy
because that's what we do to bad guys
um
and especially if it was not a bad guy
we having a connection to a relationship
with you know if you if you told me that
like Sif had become the bad guy which I
don't know what that would be but sure
then yeah it's a Redemption story it's a
can we pull her back from the break
because she used to be our best friend
um and now she's gone to the dark side
but just some Rando dude like I don't
need to see him redeemed I just need to
see you save the day of Thor
um so that is that is my off the cuff
pick
um with a with a fudgy
um Pitch for a solution
um to my issues with it but um
but yeah I mean the Wonder Woman was a
good one
um
I'm sure that there's some version of a
matrix movie specifically like the third
one
oh yeah that could have been
you know I don't even know what the
pitch is just maybe not have people
sitting in a spaceship going blind
um traveling into the void only to have
another fist fight by the end
um yeah I don't I don't know just that
one also the bigger it got the less
impactful it felt
um to the point where hey you know what
maybe we just pretend that Matrix two
three and four did never happen and I
made one great movie that's how it ended
we just took off the other 300 minutes
of content
and you can dabble in the animatrix if
you want
yes absolutely they can we can have
little little bits and pieces but we
didn't need all of that
I think that's the show that's a show
man that's a show we're gonna do it in
90 minutes we're putting in half the
effort
um well I'll push before you say goodbye
I've got a couple things I'm gonna pedal
please uh by all means first uh I'll be
hosting trivia tomorrow night so I will
not be at your engagement unfortunately
those things happen but you know I have
to be an adult and a business owner so
uh if anybody's in LA and wants to do
nerd trivia tomorrow night and then
Saturday for the first time ever
Skillman villain is going to open at 11
A.M on Saturdays and do lunch so you can
Day drink on Saturday and continue
through the evening
amazing
so oh I love it and then I'm wearing
this because I'm we may do scum and
villainy hockey jerseys
we know a guy I'm Tony so the guy who
makes all Kevin's jerseys drinks it's
scum
and he and I got to talking the other
day and he gave me this this Grimlock
Jersey
that I thought that's cool and so maybe
maybe we do a limited run scum and
villain in New Jersey if people would
buy it you know if we sold it a thousand
Jeff's kiss kiss shirts I feel like we
could do a couple hundred scum and
villainy jerseys
like yeah you can so
um anyway that's it for me awesome
that's it for you um let me plug a
couple of things I suppose
um
the I have the ongoing yes but it's an
ongoing concern for the next couple of
months
um census on the book that I uh that I
wrote with my buddy Adam Freeman and was
uh drawn and colored by Sebastian
goodies
um is coming out monthly um for the next
well issues one and two are out issue
three should be on a couple of weeks
um on comixology uh comicsology
originals and then it'll be in print and
Dark Horse next year
um but you know pick it up it's a bit of
a horror comedy
um and I think it's fun at least we had
fun writing it
um so yeah that is uh that is still sort
of bubbling around there and in a couple
weeks I will be in the United Kingdom
for the thought bubble Festival in in
Harrogate it's a comic book convention
and I'm going all the way across the
pond
Lieutenant
um I understand that it's a it's a bit
outside of London um a bit of a drive
or a train or a boat
helicopter holocrats
um but for for people who have been
asking why am I going to come across the
Atlantic to come say hi I'm doing so I
will be there
um pretty sure it's the 11th I arrive
it's Friday Saturday Sunday in a couple
weeks
um so if you're in town and want to
enter down the clown let's hang out
um and now we'll see you at our book
convention
um and I think that is it for me
which means that it's it for this
episode of black man beyond
um we will be back
um I think hopefully with Kevin
um for a fat man
um update
maybe in the next couple of weeks I know
that he is between me going to the UK
and him continuing the the convenience
store
um you know finding the time to be on
the zooms together is harder than it's
been in a while but I hope we will be
able to work it out relatively soon
um but until then until the next time I
figure out how to do a black man by
myself maybe it'll be a review episode
of wakanda forever either with me with
me by myself we can for me and some
other uh guests who agrees to come into
the chamber
um until then thank you for taking some
time on your afternoon
um we will be back same black Time same
black Channel
um I have been Mark Bernard and always
happy to see you guys
um be good stay safe
um and uh and we'll see you when we see
it
um smodcast.com or youtube.com Karen
Smith
peace
love and soul
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay inside
[Music]